hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm sick which is kind of cool
except for the fact that it's not I'm
also back from pax which is kind of cool
too but not as cool as the fact that I
could to [ __ ] about me being sick my
damn gerbil
[ __ ] you gerbil I'm gonna eat you my
gerbils name is Larry don't bother him
he's not part of this video he doesn't
want to be a part of anything so don't
bother him so today we're gonna be doing
a different type of video in celebration
of being sick because that's something
to celebrate and if it's not well then
[ __ ] me I don't care I'm on like three
different types of cold medicine and my
ability to give a [ __ ] has been
medicinally suppressed so today I'm
gonna be doing the don't cringe
challenge or try not to cringe challenge
I'm probably gonna cringe I can't even
get through Borat so if you don't know
about this challenge there's certain
videos on the Internet that when you
watch them you get the instinctive
feeling to cave your entire face into
your doors oh you know that feeling when
you watch my videos and you're like ooh
this isn't funny or entertaining yeah
that feeling so that's a good video put
that on the Internet
so there's this lovely subreddit called
cringe or our cringe if you're a
redditor and on this grouted thirst
there's a series of videos that are
cringy and they're ranked in order of
either all-time year or cringe of the
month which i'm hoping to win at some
point in the future maybe this video is
gonna get there so i'm on do is i'm
gonna go through the top ones and see
how long I can last until my entire body
chromed ences down and do a black hole
let's cringe it up I can't hear anything
goddamnit where's mature bull now we're
properly equipped to do the cringe I can
actually hear myself which is phenomenal
thing you guys can cuz my [ __ ] throat
okay anyway here we go
so far so good
I don't see anything wrong with that
video I may have been averted Lee
doesn't and don't laugh challenge but
that's how this is about alright so this
video seven minutes long but it's
already climbing to the top of our
cringe and it was posted two days ago so
it's called teacher first a cringy
[Music]
[Music]
around the room it's fine
normal people do with the education
system today oh that's fine it's rigid
oh oh oh ah no I been just through
enough pain uh everything about me is in
chief I really have started to like her
I want a hug her she's doing a great job
wanna give her a big old hug she's doing
wonderfully you [ __ ] kids
you [ __ ] kids start singing anytime
you want the goose enjoy any time
[Music]
[Music]
that one kid in the backs trying to
escape into his shirt to get away from
this but I say I want to be in that
classroom right now I think there's some
alcohol in this one
[Music]
honestly not that bad I gotta give her
credit for finishing that is in this day
she knew someone was recording her and
she still kept going on it I hope she
becomes the world's best name because
that was amazing I do not feel good not
from the video from medicine and dancing
and this video I'm removing this video
in 24 hours
good god don't what are you doing oh my
god this video is unlisted holy [ __ ] I'm
gonna share it oh my god I'm gonna share
it yes I'll put the video in the
description yes I want this teacher to
get all the love in the world this
teacher is amazing
this teacher is the best teacher she
should win awards she should win
everything I want all the love in the
world to go to this teacher she is
fantastic Oh God
I can't do this [ __ ]
I don't know why I'm trying not to laugh
I think that's kinda like blended
together a bit the reason you lift your
hand is because you already believe
you're saying I believe in up we just
give me an opportunity to confess and be
pull him in and see see a little guy in
the back little guy I'm not a [ __ ]
he's a child I mean want anyone to think
I was offending a [ __ ]
[Music]
it's fine nothing nothing can I search
for me Luna my search to our cringe
please dear God please Jack Black and
markiplier playfun a for while Jack
promotes his new film goosebumps and
clearly disinterested while Mark
desperately tries to make some jokes
I bet the comments on this are going to
be wonderful and lovely and totally in
my favor I didn't find that to be
awkward they were just shooting the [ __ ]
and talking about the movie I thought it
was a good video anyway / shrug it I
feel the same exact way I already like
Jack Black and Mark - it's too humble
and nice of a guy for me to cringe at
most of the time there are you plus his
voice is nice to listen to and he's not
freaking out oh is that so
and you call yourself a fan how's this
for a nice listen do actually answer
that I thought it'd be where are the bad
comments mark is always cringe this was
just icing on the cake he's 99.9 percent
less cringe than pewdiepie that's like
being 99.9 percent less hot than the Sun
huh okay how hot is the Sun the Sun is
five thousand seven hundred and
seventy-seven degrees Kelvin on the
surface but we want that in a system
that we probably know so five thousand
seven hours in assume K to F say which
means that it's nine thousand nine
hundred and thirty eight point nine
three degrees Fahrenheit or five
thousand five hundred and three degrees
Celsius so we know that 99.9% less means
one one thousandth so if we pull up our
handy-dandy calculator here all we have
to do is to divide 5503 185 by
but by a thousand sorry which means five
point five degrees Celsius and if you
want that in Fahrenheit I believe it was
ninety nine thirty eight point nine
thirty something like that all you have
to do is divide nine nine three eight
point nine three by a thousand and I am
nine point nine four degrees Fahrenheit
so I have mathematically proved I am
cooler than PewDiePie and the Sun so
called masse crash Oh God okay I think
I've done I've been editing for a long
time my voice is really starting to go
so I'm gonna end this here I hope you
enjoyed this video I'll try to provide
links for all the videos that I cringe
do or did not grimace - I'll leave it up
to you in the description below I'm very
tired I don't feel well but I really
hope you enjoyed this video I'll try to
get more regular videos out soon I'm
chugging down as much gold Matt as soon
as I can but that never actually cures
you it just masks the symptoms and I
need water for my throat so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye